do you agree with the home secretary  that the police should be a bit less  woke apparently  well that's what pretty fatality things  should spend less time on parades less  time taking the knee more time policing  well i've just seen i just seen them i i  tell you what i've seen a bunch of  police officers who who woke up quite a  lot of drug dealers this morning and  they woke them long before they were  expecting to have their uh their  breakfast they when they worked they  woke them uh with uh with warrants and  they woke them with the news that they  were under arrest for uh causing misery  in in the communities of  and that's that's what i want the police  to do that's what pretty wants them to  do i thank them for what they're doing  they do an absolutely fantastic job